hello again as you can hear i have not
been fired by letitia yet
let's have a look at some more community
questions that were either interesting
or caused some confusion within the
answers
so for the first questions opinions were
divided most of you actually think that
the gradients of individual pixels show
you something useful the gradients
regarding the output that is
what was meant here was simple take for
example a classifier that gets an image
and predicts a cat we now want to know
what does the network actually look at
for that we simply get the gradient of
each individual pixel regarding the
output that is we see how much the
output actually changes if we slightly
change a pixel's value in theory that
may sound great but the information of a
single pixel can be somewhat deceiving
simple arguments against something like
that at least in our opinion would be
for example what adversarial attacks do
there you also look at pixels and see
how you want to change those pixels to
have a network predict a different class
as a result a really tiny disturbance
can already cause a totally different
classification simple pixel information
seems to be very unstable and not super
reliable at least for many cases where i
personally have looked at that and there
are actual papers that look at that too
these examples here compute simple
gradients for each pixel regarding the
output class that has been produced
showing what is important to produce
this label for the image as you can see
this is super noisy and often pixels on
the object itself are not even the most
important ones like for example for the
camera the lens is actually not
important in this visualization a more
refined solution is what they suggest
instead compute the gradient not just
for one single pixel and its current
color but integrate over the gradient of
differently blended versions of the
image for example blending from black to
the actual image
and that then gets rid of some of the
noise and produces something that is
more stable for example if we now look
at the camera again we can now see that
the lens actually seems to help in the
classification and seems to be important
for that if you want to know more about
this you can find the integrated
gradients paper and a great distal
article with more on that topic in the
description box below
similar to the last question this one
also aims at better understanding what a
neural network actually does internally
consider for example a classifier for
images again we then look at our single
examples and split them into different
groups by some characteristics and we do
that splitting in the deeper layers of
the network for example we split the
data set in images with and without
water in the background now the normal
of that hyperplane that splits our data
and the latent space is now actually a
direction in which we can move an image
representation for example in this case
to make it more or less watery in the
sense of what the network actually
perceives and we can now use that to
even measure how important that water is
for a classification result we can
compute the gradient of this direction
with respect to the output of the
network through that we see how the
output of the classifier actually
changes if we move a sample and the
latent space along that hyperplane
normal that is how the output changes if
we make an image more or less watery for
example for the ship class we should see
that making an image more or less watery
should have an impact on the classifier
output as i've been told that chips
usually are in water and thus it's a
good cue to be used for the class label
and coming back to the initial question
we can also measure that way how
important for example a text label is in
an image for the resulting
classification and this is great for
example to see if your network just
cheats on a task by abusing some for
example text labels that have been hard
coded in the image a paper that looks at
all of that in depth called tcaf and
that tries to measure that and quantify
that in some way as linked below it's a
really interesting and well-written
paper that gives you a lot of new ways
to view at what a network does
internally and how we can actually put
that to numbers
we then had two questions about vector
quantized variation and auto encoders
while those don't sound that exciting
remember that they enable for a great
deal of things like dali
in principle a vq vae is an auto encoder
where the latent space is quantized that
is you encode some input then round that
latent code to the closest codebook
value and then decode that discretized
value to obtain the original input again
this learnt discrete representation then
works a bit better for some tasks
because you can more easily use for
example transformers on it that are
built for discrete inputs also some
things in the real world like words or
handwritten digits are just discrete so
it comes more naturally to express them
through a discrete representation now
this code book that we are using to
discretize the encoder output is also
learned during training which means that
for the lust function we now have the
original reconstruction laws just as for
a normal boring autoencoder
and two parts to regularize the latent
space to better fit the values of the
codebook while also moving the used code
book items closer to the samples
if we now just drop that vector
quantization part namely those two extra
losses that adapt the code book to the
latent codes and the latent codes to the
code book all that's left is the
autoencoder reconstruction loss and
without that discretization well we then
just have a plain old auto encoder and
that also means that we no longer get
the properties similar to a variational
autoencoder namely a nice and tidy
latent through using this code book
similar to that question before look at
let's what happens if we make the code
book of a vq vae infinitely large
for the loss functions remember that we
take our encoded image and then quantize
that to the nearest codebook values
before we decode that now there are two
possible interpretations of that
questions that largely depend on the
initial distribution of the let's see
one dimensional here code book and the
initial distribution of the latent first
of all if we say that an infinite code
book would actually mean a code book
with all possible code words in it then
we would have all the possible numbers
our encoder could come up with in there
if that's the case then both the losses
would become 0. if every latent part is
actually in the code book then we would
not need to move our codebook closer to
the encoder output or move the output of
the encoder closer to the codebook and
as a result these terms are always zero
and we just have a regular old boring
autoencoder and that is what i was
actually going for with this question
but as the comments pointed out that's
not the only possible interpretation for
the other possible interpretation let's
say that our infinite code book has a
certain distribution for example having
numbers from -1 to 1. if our encoder
luckily falls into that range and we
stay there great we are not going to
have any quantization related losses
that are non-zero but if we produce an
encoding that gets out of that range
things get a little bit hairy if we have
a value outside that range say smaller
than -1 we move that value that comes
out of the encoder towards -1 by moving
the code book entry with -1 towards that
actual value however we just move that
one entry from the boundary there not
touching any of the other values in the
code book for now as the code book is
only adapted for those code words that
are actually used so now we have code
book that has some values being
quantized and some not being quantized
and over the iterations that will just
spread out and we for example end up
with something like this we have a core
dense region between -1 and 1 where
quantization doesn't do anything because
all the values are in that code book and
then there is a region where we just
regularly discretize
so this will eventually act like a
regular auto encoder for anything inside
-1 and 1
and like a regular vq vae outside of
that which is somewhat weird can you
come up with a useful scenario for that
or do you even think that we overlooked
something and we get an entirely
different behavior if so hit us up in
the comments because for now that seems
more like a pile of rubbish to me next
up is a fantastic question yay thank you
for that we wanted to know whether one
could use pearson's correlation
coefficient to actually disentangle the
latent space of a neural network well
disentangling basically means that we
want the latent of our neural network to
be nice and tidy for example that an
auto encoder of handwritten digits is
actually split into different
characteristics like having one variable
on the latent express thickness and the
other variable in the latent expressing
the number which is actually displayed
sadly an unregularized latent space
isn't that cleaned up and these
characteristics are all over the place
maybe we want the distribution where
this latent space is nicely split into
one variable having thickness and the
other one containing the digits all nice
and tidy but in truth they are actually
looking like this instead with one
variable having both characteristics in
them a little bit
and that's just one possible way but
this is something we actually do not
want for disentangled representation
what's important is that these variables
are somewhat correlated in the latent
space now meaning that for example when
we have some information about the
x-axis we also get some information
about the y-axis as well if we're on
this part of the x-axis we know that we
can only be in this part of the y-axis
now throwing pearson's correlation
coefficient on the loss to enforce that
from x we can no longer linearly
extrapolate y would somewhat prevent
that but there are a whole bunch of
issues with that we would just prevent a
linear correlation that pearson's
correlation coefficient measures nothing
more anything non-linear is not really
caught by that and as these networks are
really sneaky they can just choose to
hide these properties in some non-linear
fashion to circumvent that still being
all messy and untangled and for the last
part let's now get to the juicy geometry
regarding point clouds there's a whole
bunch of reasons why they are messy to
work with from these answers the numbers
of points is clearly not a problem one
could say that 128 points are actually
all you need to see that this is a chair
opposing to an amnesty image where you
would have for example 28 by 28 pixels
and you'd already end up with 784 values
however permutation invariance is a
thing though you don't have a canonical
order of those points like you would
have for images or voxels that are
essentially just grids with values in
them to explain one of the ideas to get
around that that was already mentioned
in the comments thank you for that let's
go quickly over the idea of pointnet you
find the link to the well-written paper
in the description box the key idea is
simple put the points through a function
that is permutation invariant as well
for example if we take the maximum of a
b and c that is the same as the maximum
of b c and a so maximum is a symmetric
function and that's what they are
essentially using to become permutation
invariant put all points through such a
function what they then do is they take
every single point individually apply a
shared neural network to it to load it
up say to a thousand dimensions and then
apply max pooling across every dimension
ending up with 1000 maximum values that
form your embedding of the input cloud
so by using the symmetric function we
got rid of the permutation sensitivity
while also not really carrying how many
points we actually put in here because
we always end up with 1000 values and
this resulting embedding you can then
process to for example classify whether
the input model is a plane or a chair
aside from permutation invariants you
have a bunch of other issues though not
properly defined convolution operator
varying densities you'd get from a laser
scanner etc and lots of more fun with
geometry and that's just the issues you
have for point clouds triangle measures
are even worse if you ask me so thank
you for staying with me until the end if
you have any cool suggestions for
community questions just send them and
we will credit you hope to see you again